30 minute workouts
20 minute recipes 10 minute mindfulness
ready to become
[Music]
get feel on the app store or google play
why is it so important to boost or
increase your metabolism simply put the
higher your metabolic rate is the more
calories you burn hence the easier it is
to lose weight and keep it off
someone with a sluggish or slow
metabolism will gain more fat from
eating less food in comparison to a
person with a fast healthy metabolism so
what affects your metabolism genetics
age
weight
diet exercise habits as well as
lifestyle there are certain areas in
which we can't control such as our genes
and also age
as we age we start to lose five to six
pounds of muscles every decade starting
in our late 20s so if you choose to do
absolutely nothing about it that's when
you'll start to see the weight pile on
as you age
saying that however there are also areas
which we can control our weight
diet
exercise routine and lifestyle
these are the areas we should take
control of and it can speed up our
metabolism so i'm going to share with
you 8 effective ways to boost your
metabolism burn fat and lose weight
the only way to increase lean muscle
mass is to lift weights
for every pound of lean muscle your body
burns an additional 14 calories a day
whereas a pound of fat only burns 2 to 3
calories
this small difference can add up over
time hence people who are leaner with
higher muscle mass burns more calories
at rest compared to those with higher
body fat adding strength training two to
three times a week burns significantly
more fat than those who only perform
cardio exercises resistant training can
involve using the machines in the gym or
free weights such as dumbbells barbells
kettlebells or equipment such as a
resistance band or even body weight
exercises such as push-ups and pull-ups
swap steady-paced cardio for h-i-i-t
yes going for a long jaw can be great to
burn calories but it isn't the most
efficient or effective way to achieve
that lean physique you're after high
intensity interval training or more
commonly known as hiit
involves quick and exert intense bursts
of energy implementing a consistent heat
routine requires your body to consume
more oxygen making your mitochondria
work harder and burn more energy heat
training can burn a similar amount of
calories in half the time compared to a
low intensity steady-based cardio not
only will you be saving time you'll reap
the benefits of a hit workout even after
the session so after your heat workout
your body continues to burn calories for
up to 36 hours by increasing your
metabolic rate
that boost of metabolism will not be
possible through a steady-paced cardio
training you can very easily incorporate
interval training into your workout by
inserting a 30 second sprint into your
jog or bike followed by a one minute
recovery and repeat this cycle for 10
times if you aren't gasping for air
you aren't exerting enough effort for it
to be considered a heat training it has
to be intense
don't starve yourself yes in order to
lose weight you need a calorie deficit
however an extreme calorie deficiency
long term can wreck havoc on your
metabolism if you're underfeeding your
body on a regular basis your metabolism
will adapt to the new lower calorie
intake
your metabolism works more efficiently
to try and preserve the remaining
calories hence slowing down your
metabolism yes
you will lose weight but is this
sustainable
once you were to go back to your normal
ways of eating or increase your food
intake that's when you will start piling
on the weight again
and it happens really fast
avoid extreme diets instead reduce your
calorie intake at a healthy and
realistic pace which can help you lose
weight and at the same time you know
that you can sustain this for life
fourth power up with protein tep which
is also known as the thermic effect of
food is caused by the extra calories
your body uses to digest absorb and
process the nutrients in your meal
protein causes the largest rice in tep
as it is harder for your body to break
it down it raises your metabolic rate by
15 to 30 percent compared to 5 to 10 for
cubs and zero to three percent for fats
therefore consuming plenty of protein
can make you burn an extra 100 to 200
calories a day plus you will also feel
more full and prevent overeating eating
large amounts of carbohydrates without
any protein will spike your blood sugar
levels only to have it crash one or two
hours later this cycle will wreck havoc
on your metabolism and leave you
fatigued and in a constant state of
hunger that doesn't mean you have to
consume a very high protein diet the
guideline to simply follow is check that
20 to 30 percent of your total daily
calories come from protein and the
easiest method i like to follow is to
have a serving of protein such as lean
meat fish nuts legumes or yogurt at
every meal and snack
next sip on black coffee
studies have shown that the caffeine in
coffee can boost metabolism by 3 to 11
percent and this is why if you were to
take a look at fat burners most of them
have caffeine as the number one
ingredient that doesn't mean that you
should be a caffeine addict and just sip
on coffee all day long expecting to lose
weight you still need to put in the
effort
drinking a cup of black coffee before
exercising can improve your workout
performance speed up your metabolism
hence help you burn fat more efficiently
and that's something i personally
practice myself so one cup of joe before
my training
exercising has tons of benefits however
if you have a sedentary life where
you're set on your desk for eight hours
every single day and you only move for
an hour in the gym
that's probably not the best way to
boost your metabolism throughout the day
the goal here is to move more sitting
too much kills you and it's even dubbed
as the new smoking
long periods of sitting burn fewer
calories and can lead to weight gain and
many other health issues
an effective way to increase your
metabolism with very minimal effort is
to stand up and move more perhaps
work from a standing desk or set
yourself a reminder to move every hour
get up get yourself a cup of tea do some
simple stretches or just walk around
your office
make the effort to move more by walking
to get lunch taking public transport or
taking the stairs
all these daily incidental movements can
help you to burn more calories and even
lose weight with very minimal effort
we all know the importance of water but
did you know that your body needs water
to process calories
hence if you are even slightly
dehydrated your metabolism may slow down
some simple tricks to drink more water
daily is to drink a glass once you're up
in the morning and drink a glass of
water before every meal or consume a
healthy vegetable soup before your meal
and also snack on fresh fruits and
vegetables which naturally contain water
water helps to fill you up which means
those who drink more water will tend to
consume less food what you really need
to avoid are sugary drinks and alcohol
as they contain empty calories but can
add up over time and cause weight gain
and i can't stress this enough get
enough rest
lack of sleep can be linked to being
overweight
sleeping is something we don't
prioritize in our busy and active
lifestyle not getting enough rest can
disrupt your hormones change the way you
process sugar and decrease the number of
calories you burn sleep affects the
levels of two hormones leptin and
ghrelin which control the feelings of
fullness and hunger
leptin sends a signal to your brain that
you have had enough to eat without
enough sleep your brain reduces leptin
and raises ghrelin which is an appetite
stimulant hence when you lack sleep you
will also notice that you eat and crave
more
you're in control of your body's
metabolic rate don't blame it on your
genetics or age making small lifestyle
changes on a daily basis can boost your
metabolism and you will only thank
yourself for it a high metabolism can
help with weight loss maintaining a
healthy weight for life and more
importantly it gives you more energy to
do the things you enjoy and truly live
life what other methods have you tried
to increase your metabolism let me know
in the comments below be sure to give
this video a thumbs up and check out a
lot more fitness tips on my youtube
channel and i will see you in my next
video bye